guerre en ukraine
176e jours déjà la contre offensive de
kiev se poursuit notamment dans le sud
de la crimée ce territoire annexé par le
kremlin s'était en 2014 sur place je
vous lisez une base militaire russe a
été endommagée explosions entendues près
de la ville de sébastopol on retrouve
notre envoyé spécial en ukraine mélina
huet bonjour mélina vous en savez plus
écoutés florent vous l'avez dit cette
péninsule annexé en 2014 est la cible de
nombreuses frappes depuis un peu plus
d'une semaine alors qu'elle n'avait
jamais été visé directement par les
ukrainiens depuis 2014 et plusieurs
frappes ont été recensés cette nuit à
deux endroits très stratégique 1 tout
d'abord acquiert chez à sébastopol or
pour recontextualiser un petit peu fier
c'est un fait totalement à l'est de la
crimée de cette péninsule et si les
ukrainiens frappe bien cet endroit car
il ne revendique jamais les frappes mais
qui d'autre pour tenter de d'attaquer la
crimée qui est donc une base arrière de
la russie qui sert à réapprovisionner
ses troupes dans le sud de l'ukraine
qu'elle occupe pour le moment est bien
le pont de pierre schielé frappé et s'il
est visé en tout cas c'est pour deux
raisons la première est évidemment
stratégique c'est un pont de 18 km de
long qui est le seul qui relie le cren à
la russie et qui donc permet
d'approvisionner
l'allaiter forces russes dans le sud de
l'ukraine via la craie met le deuxième
point c'est qu'il est très symbolique ce
pont depuis ce que pendant des années
l'ukraine et la russie avaient tenté
conjointement d'en créer un notamment un
sou medvedev et puis il ya eu 2014 et la
guerre est passée par là alors poutine a
décidé de relancer la construction de ce
pont et l'a inauguré en grande pompe en
2018 histoire de marquer le territoire
d'expliquer que la crimée était bel et
bien à lui et donc le deuxièmement droit
donc ça c'est la première partie des
frappes qui ont été recensés cette nuit
la deuxième partie c'est à sébastopol en
réalité c'est pas vraiment sébastopol
qui est visé c'est plutôt l'aérodrome de
belpech le plus gros de la crimée qui a
été frappé déjà il y a trois semaines
par les ukrainiens a priori et qui a
empêché une parade militaire de l'armée
russe mais c'est surtout un aérodrome
dont il ya potentiellement des intérêts
militaires a frappé cette base là savoir
que les ukrainiens affirment que depuis
quelques jours les russes ont
rapatrié plus de 24 avions et et 12
hélicoptères de combat depuis la crimée
jusqu'à la rue si on ne sait pas
exactement où donc c'est cette pression
constante de l'ukraine sur la russie
semble fonctionner en tout cas puisque
les troupes russes commencent à tout le
moins à s'angoisser un de l'idée de
frappes répétées sur cette péninsule